as the most excellent transmission  medium  optical fiber combined with p2mp  architecture  are the solid basis for the success of  pawn technology  in the past 10 years at present  fttx accounts for 50 percentage of  market share  both a 10 times increase on the number  of broadband users  and elevated the worldwide average  excess bandwidth  over 100 megabits the current global  changes  of uncertainty have increasingly  highlighted the importance of  fpb as a key infrastructure  in optical access field dt the leverage  is leading core capabilities  advanced product architectures and  scenario solutions  to help globe operators upgrade their  network infrastructure  and unleash business value